I've been doing this ask me anything on
Reddit and I've been doing my best to
keep up with the the questions but my
fingers are getting tired and so I
thought I would I would use as a backup
what I'm used to doing which is make a
video on the question so this is the the
ask me anything I posted this earlier
today and I put this little picture of
myself to verify that it was actually me
and so here are the questions and I'll
try not to be redundant so I'm gonna
focus on the questions that I haven't
answered so this first one has it in
spot as an aspiring teacher do you have
any tips for new teachers and then I I
did make a little short comment and
you're not my best teachers I felt were
the ones that kind of talked with us
that treated us as equals rather than
kind of we're at the board and and
talked at us or or in some way belittled
us and I don't think most teachers do
that but some do and it didn't feel good
and I would say on top of that I think
kind of the the the energy or the
interest or the passion that someone
takes into a subject is it there's a
pretty good indicator of of how students
will perceive the subject I think human
beings are very cute into other people's
tonality and and more than fact more
cuter than most people realize and so if
you yourself as a teacher are not
passionate and really interested in what
you're saying and really excited about
it it's going to be very hard to get
students there so I would say talk with
them be conversational make sure it's
clear that you're on the same side as
them that it's not you against them and
and show a real deep passion for the
subject and obviously it wouldn't hurt
if you if you have a very deep grounding
in what you're teaching and I think if
that happens you'll do you'll do just
fine now let's go down here there's a
bunch of comments here but I'll try to
focus at these top level questions so so
at someone here I think had a very good
comment teacher kid's passion and love
the subject and not first study for the
test and I think once again a lot of
that comes from comes from the tone and
and the the passion that the teacher
themselves have and then you say which
subject did you enjoy teaching the most
and I had a little answer here and it is
true I found subjects that ten years ago
if you were to ask me do you find that
interesting I don't know I haven't
really looked into that deeply but once
I start really getting into the subject
I've been making a few videos very
recently about agriculture and I am
finding them as interesting as any of
the
videos that I've done about galactic
collisions or or the financial crisis
and it really is just how you view it
all of these things really do tell us
about how the universe is structured and
how we as humans came about being who we
are so let's see let's see what else I
can answer here so there's some very
nice comments that's a nice quote
they're not mine those who seek beauty
will find it I agree I see this person
right over here is C T Nguyen chemistry
thanks for videos or this was thank you
okay oh how long does it take you to
create one of your tutorial videos and I
did answer a little bit and and my
comment depends on what I'm doing if I'm
doing a fairly straightforward algebra
worked example it'll take me really the
length of the video I like to do in real
time it lets the the thought process
actually show up in the video if I'm
doing something like the this just now I
made a video on on Thomas Malthus and
his views on population limits and
things like that
I I have I already knew about Thomas
Malthus and his views but I did read up
a little bit I spent a couple hours
making sure that I had all the
interesting ideas that he was and making
sure that I had his ideas straight and
but then I just made the video I didn't
I don't like to script or over-prepare
because it kind of kills spontaneity
that way and sometimes if I'm doing a
video on something that's a relatively I
would say new concept for example I took
organic chemistry in college and I did
just fine in it but I felt when I went
through it in college I didn't get
gained an intuition for the subject and
one of my kind of litmus test for
whether I will do a video is do I have
an intuition do I have a passion for the
subject and for me to do that in organic
chemistry it took me about two weeks I
immersed myself with tons of textbooks
ask people questions and then I kind of
got it I got the intuition and then I
was ready to really teach it and I
wanted it because I wanted to teach it
so it wasn't based on memorization of
mechanisms I wanted people to see the
underlying underpinnings of organic
chemistry and so there are a couple of
comments there and I'm still trying to
I'm a relatively new reddit user so I am
I'm still trying to figure out figure
out the best way to use it and so let's
see someone was envious you get to learn
new subjects they should be I consider
myself the luckiest guy on the planet
that was my comment right over
they're it's true I'm having the time of
my life I see there's all these other
comments as he load more comments load
more comments let's see me scroll down
just a little bit I see one way on your
way to work I thought you quit your job
yes I did quit my old job in finance but
then I started doing the Khan Academy
full-time and so you might call it a
work in quotation marks but but this is
where I work now and so yes I work at
the Khan Academy okay okay I'm glad they
decided to hire you yes I am glad that
the Khan Academy decided to hire me as
well they hired him because he is in the
CEOs family just look at his last names
true nepotism in its worst form
occurring at the Khan Academy have the
same last name as the founder although
for not-for-profit not the CEO the
executive director and then let's see
Khan Academy equals job the grow on job
ease I don't understand that they grow
on job ease Oh what our jobs I see I
guess so let's see this is all right so
let's see I'm trying to my best to get
through them I think there's like 1,500
or 2,000 comments here so let's see
I remember fishing Organa I never want
to say thank you for putting a great F
okay let's see okay I don't let's see I
don't do any prep yes that's not
surprising and perhaps sorcerer caster
could comment but yes I try not to do
any significant scripting the way I tell
people is prep your mind I try to get
the concepts the concepts distilled down
as much as possible and for me to really
click have some clarity around it but
I'd like to be a little extemporaneous
in the actual delivery of the video it
makes it keeps it fun for me I'd say
let's see okay this guy just this or
this gal just discovered that we do have
organic chemistry videos and then what
did you use to study I forgot the exact
names of the books I had my old organic
textbook I think it was a Kemp was a
professor and he was my professor in
college too
and he was actually quiet quite a good
professor you had kind of this dramatic
speaking voice and all the rest action
would be pretty neat to get him to do
YouTube videos okay where has your site
had the biggest impact have you seen
much use in developing nations can you
share your best success stories well we
from day one and into large degree this
is what has motivated me to keep going
is we've got tons of letters and if you
go to our YouTube channel you'll see
them or our Facebook page I asked for
some testimonials recently I'm in the
process of writing a book and and we got
some of these pretty amazing
testimonials this was one of them that I
copied and pasted I covered his name up
although he probably wouldn't mind
sharing him this was a kind of a
mind-blowing story he was into drugs and
then he kind of became a really awesome
student and then some other people
contributed right over here I mean these
are pretty cool stories too and then
let's see we got this one in South
Africa there's a ton of these and
actually we're hoping to collate these
and so that the world can see it at
least the there's no doubt in our mind
and I say are not just me because we're
a team now we're 22 people and we're
growing as an organization but there's
no doubt in our mind that there are
people out there because they're sending
us their letters and their videos that
have been heavily influenced by some of
the work we've done and frankly in our
minds these people you know did 99% of
it and we just gave them the the tools
the outlet for them to it to improve
themselves but we're also seeing more I
guess you'd call analytical data on on a
more controlled setting so for example
in Los Altos and Los Altos is a fluent
area but they also piloted Khan Academy
with their algebra readiness kind of a
was kind of a remedial math class most
of these students were not affluent most
of them did not come from families that
spoke English at home or that had had
college degrees and and that we saw very
promising results last year double the
number of students who are at grade
level in six months and some of them
leap frogged ahead to be advanced which
as we had never expected and the school
district hadn't seen that before where
students in a remedial class actually
jump ahead of the kids who weren't in
the remedial class and so that's why
they've broadened
the program this year and we've also
this year started some pilots in other
classrooms some charter schools public
private schools in different
demographics and so far the results have
been very promising and and and you know
our goal is Khan Academy will always be
primarily for the bulk of students who
are using it independently of any any
formal structure but we think it can be
kind of it can supercharge what happens
if you do have access to an amazing
classroom and so what we hope to do with
these pilots
it isn't a prove or not prove although
it is definitely awesome validation when
we get the kind of a type of data that
we saw in Los Altos our goal is to see
how can this work does it what settings
is applicable then what settings is it
not applicable in and and where it is
applicable seeing how we can improve it
what are the best practices what are the
things that that lead to better results
so the real exciting thing is that we
have a platform it has traction we're
getting data on it and in our minds we
can only improve from where we are but
we think we're at the very early stages
of what's going on all right let me get
the questions all right when do you plan
on making more advanced videos like
quantum mechanics general activity and
more advanced mathematics thanks and I
love everything you do what that thank
you yes we want to do all of the above
I do not know quantum mechanics and the
depth that I need to know in order to
make videos on it tomorrow
so we are I have had a few conversations
with people who might be good at that
and but it's always an interesting
question of what what constitutes good
because they should have deep subject
expertise they should have I would call
them they should be good communicators
and when I say good communicators not
just good or oratorical skills but they
should be able to get in the mind of the
learner and understand what the learner
might be having trouble with and then
for that small subset of people you have
to find the ones that want to spend a
lot of time making YouTube videos but
we're working on it and they will exist
soon and what was especially exciting
there was a gentleman right over here
and is this is his handle right over
here who's one of the leaders in in
quantum computing and looks like he is
that small subset of people who is
interested in not only being a leader in
his field but also maybe making YouTube
videos so the rest of us can understand
my quantum computing so I look forward
to a future conversation with Michael
Nielsen we've already we've already
contacted each other and so let's see
what other questions are there let's
list what other questions are there I'm
looking for the questions all right
let's see I'm a student terribly
bureaucratic school system one of the
biggest problems see is that many
inner-city students simply don't care or
apathetic do you have any suggestions on
how we can motivate them to learn and
enjoy it too so that they can make the
curve as I already answered it in tax
a very hard question I don't claim to
have some magic solution to that on one
off basis on one off Basie's we are
seeing Minh couraging things we've
worked with some charter schools or
starting to work with some charter
schools this year in underserved
communities and and we are seeing that
when you allow the students to kind of
have a self-directed version of learning
when they can kind of set goals for
themselves and then see how well they
achieve those goals when when the
culture of the classroom isn't about
passively listening to the teacher but
actively working on your own goals and
helping each other and working alongside
of the teacher it does look like it's
it's kind of a universal thing that that
people really do get into it and so but
but we don't know we don't know the
answer and and this is something that
we're going to constantly try it try to
work on and and see see what can happen
so let's see why don't you have all the
answers Kahn yes all right let's see who
or what inspired you to take so much
time to do something significant so
significant as I answered I when I
started this you know and I think if you
read the rest of the start it'll be
clear that I answer I read a lot of
science fiction books but when I started
it you know sometimes when I daydreamed
about it I hoped that it would be
something that many many people could
use there was kind of this idea there's
no reason why it couldn't be but at the
same time I had tried many ventures half
that never got any traction so I at this
point had become I guess mature enough
to realize that you know it's one thing
to have an idea it's another thing to
actually maybe have it be useful but
what excited me from the beginning was
even for those first cousins that I was
working with and for those very first
people who happened to bump into the
content on YouTube it seemed like it you
know based on what they were telling me
that it was having a real impact and so
just that made it really worthwhile to
make the content and it was kind of a
fun idea that at minimum it would be
just kind of a little thing for our
family and and for the small percentage
of people on in the world who happened
to bump into them and it's been a little
surreal because it's seeming it looks
like it's turned into but much more than
that
okay and you ever think about what
you've achieved with the Khan Academy in
the short amount of time it's been
around and if so how does it make you
feel do you feel like you have a legacy
and I did answer this already but I
think it's a you know it's it's been
amazing and strange and even looking at
how many people have shown up for this
thread is kind of strange for me because
I am a guy sitting literally in a
six-dollar t-shirt in a you know in a
room someplace wearing sneakers you know
not not not expecting much many people
to to care much but they're here III try
you know I think I think I look at a lot
of other examples of things that kind of
had these kind of meteor orc meteoric
Rises and then kind of crashed and
burned and my biggest fear is I do not
want Khan Academy to be that and so for
myself and the entire team here and and
all of our supporters I think the main
thing is we put our head down continue
to execute continue to iterate continue
to make what we have better and better
that we use the attraction that we have
in the reach that we have is really a
huge responsibility to be as good as
possible and hopefully if we keep doing
that we'll we'll be able to to be
relevant not just next year but 10 years
from now or maybe even a hundred years
from now and so that's that's that's
what we're trying to do and you know I
try not to think about things like
legacies too much it's it's not helpful
for actually maybe getting getting the
work done all right okay so this is
these are actually the original
questions from the from the asking me
anything request and I did answer all of
them but I'll answer them now verbally
just because it seems a little bit more
natural for me when you're recording
your first lectures do you have any
particular student you've made you've
made in your mind that you are talking
to does that student change depending on
the videos difficulty or message yeah
frankly I kind of imagine how I was when
I first tried to address the topic the
questions that jumped in my head the
type of things that I would have liked
to see that would have interested me in
the topic I so so it's kind of me and I
don't think that there's and I'd you
know I I'm there's not I don't have a
lot of data to go one way or another on
this but but my sense and I guess to
some degree the popularity of the video
speak to this
is that fifth fifth graders want to be
spoken to the same way than a ninth
grader or that a thirty year old wants
to be spoken to they want to be spoken
to with respect they want kind of a
conversational tone they don't want you
know to be talked down to they want they
want you know they like things that are
interesting they're the things that are
interesting to a 50 year old are
interesting to a a oftentimes to a 5th
grader and and so you'll I think you'll
see a very similar tone if you go from
the basic arithmetic video on Khan
Academy all the way to videos on the
financial crisis or vector calculus or
differential equations or linear algebra
they all essentially have the same tone
which is the tone that I'm speaking with
right now number two how much
preparation goes into the lecture in
terms of research do you have notes with
you as you lecture do you consult people
for certain subjects once again complete
depend on the lecture if I'm just doing
a worked example and say algebra
I literally just do it in real time I
four ninety five ninety nine percent of
the lectures I or videos I don't have
notes sometimes especially in history
I've done this I have a little Word
document I have two monitors and I have
a little word document on one monitor
that I retype all of the names so that I
don't misspell them because that is my
Achilles heel I have trouble with
spelling and so it's and it's
embarrassing if you're trying to look
smart when you speaking about the French
Revolution and you forgot how to spell
Napoleon so I definitely do try to do
that okay do consult people on certain
subjects it's not happened a lot I think
every now and then I've tried it has
helped a few times especially in some of
the immunology videos I had a friend me
kaluf dig that I was a professor at Duke
that I clarified some things with but
but it comes up sometimes in
conversation at parties and things but
for the most part I'm able to clarify my
thinking kind of fairly independently
three if you had the opportunity to talk
to the president about the education
system what would be the one thing you
wish you would understand most and I did
answer this and in my answer I said that
making sure that people are clear on
what we're trying to do that I feel
somewhat so many times the conversation
is on high school graduation rates or
college graduation rates or college
degrees that people are losing sight of
what's in
important which is everyone should be a
happy and productive individual and the
reason why I think those are sometimes a
disconnect because people are saying oh
let's get people college degrees no
matter what without a lot of scrutiny of
well are they are they are they getting
things through that college experience
that is likely to make them happy and
productive sometimes they're getting
into a lot of debt sometimes they're not
learning things are getting credentials
that will help them integrate or get
jobs or whatever it might whatever the
end goals might be and so I think the
important thing is to think about the
what what we're trying to get is happy
and productive people and then think
about how do we get there and and I
think you know I'll i talk about this
later on is I think we way we get there
is we have credentials that are
independent of of any of any particular
way of learning the material and very
rigorous credentials and I think if you
do that it allows people to prepare for
them in any way that they see fit they
can get those I would call the micro
cadet credentials relative to a college
degree a college degree you have to take
you know all of these courses what do
you take you take like 40 courses on
average over the course of your college
to career and you have this GPA that
somehow encapsulate some average is how
you did on history with how you did on
math and computer science and and that
doesn't give a lot of information to to
employers and they don't even know how
how and I'm not saying that employers
are the most important thing it's also
important that people have satisfying
lives but at the end of the day if they
don't have a job it's hard to focus on
much else and I've been there so so yes
so number four could you cite examples
of a foreign education systems which you
think the US should mimic no I think I
think and I answer this in text the
there there are education systems where
the kids do better on standardized tests
on certain standardized tests I know
from personal experience that well some
of those countries aren't as as large
and and aren't as educating as large of
a population as we are in the United
States and frankly at the end of the day
the United States still is kind of the
engine of innovation for the world it is
where I mean if you look in the last 20
years all the major innovations a
surprising number of them show up from
the 5% of the world that is American and
so I don't think it's it's about
America's Americans emulating other P
well actually think it's about turning
the American education system into a
more American education system right now
it's it's essentially it's a Prussian
education system the Prussians invented
you know we wanted a universal education
so we have to do it cheaply and
efficiently so let's have kids in
lockstep in these age based grades they
all move together at the same pace and
eighth grade we start tracking students
into one track or another but it doesn't
emphasize creativity it doesn't
emphasize open-ended thinking and so I'd
like to see a more American model where
students have independence they're
learning at their own pace they've taken
control of their own learning they can
decide how to achieve a very high a very
rigorous credential in any way that they
see fit whether it is going through a
formal institution whether it's doing an
apprenticeship whether there's some
combination of all of the above so so no
I wouldn't I wouldn't copy any other
country I would make the American
education system a more American alright
who are a few people who respect greatly
in terms of character achievement I I
listed them I listed them over here in a
mark twain I just incase hilarious and
and brilliant and whatever else Muhammad
Yunus you know he's addressing a boldly
addressing a world problem that many
people many cynical people would have
thought was kind of hard to address and
he's done it in kind of outside of the
realm of formal institutions where he's
created his own institution to do it
outside of the realm of governments but
although he does he does coordinate with
governments Bill Cosby I just love
listening to him and I think he's
brilliant richard fineman I you know one
of my inspirations he made me want to be
a theoretical physicist at one point
Bill Gates who I've had the you know
Massoud cheesy listing him because he's
obviously one of our big supporters and
he's also a controversial figure for
better for worse people some people love
him Pete some people hate him but
especially after I've had a chance to
meet him I can testify that you know he
is he's he's he's he has redefined
philanthropy and he's really in it as
rationally as possible trying to save as
many lives as possible and and when I
say save lives it means one keep them
from dying but assuming that they are
living giving them as much opportunity
as possible
for him it's not about his ego it's not
about putting his names on things it's
literally about what are we doing what
we need to do and so I think it's
incredibly powerful and and having met
him a few times now I could tell you
it's amazing considering the level that
he's in in life how deep he's willing to
go into different subjects that you know
he's naturally curious naturally wants
to dig deep into issues and understand
them for him for himself as opposed to
kind of having other people tell him
necessarily what the answer is he wants
to make sure that it that it feels right
to him
and so I respected him before but even
more so now so I sometimes find it weird
when people kind of criticize him
especially for his philanthropic work
because literally hundreds of thousands
of people are alive because of him
number three number three if you had the
opportunity oh can I read that I see
site examples let's see would you ever
seek a government position involved in
education Secretary of Education as I
said no no no no no no no disrespect to
that position but I just you know I
think I'm better off being kind of close
you know close to the road or where the
rubber hits the road and and working on
the content and that's where I feel best
seven in the future would you like video
lectures to be the primary source of
receiving information who would you like
to see cert making certain videos well
when I say primary well when it's the
primary source of receiving information
I don't know if I'd necessarily agree
with that I view videos as one source of
receiving information when you when you
need it I'd actually prefer a lot of the
learning to happen kind of as people
experiment and work on things what I
think the videos do is is they take they
really throw into question the the idea
of passive lectures because you can I'd
argue that on-demand video is better in
almost every way than the traditional
passive lecture and it frees up time to
do more of that that hands-on hands-on
learning but in terms of people making
certain videos we're looking for them I
mean I've there there are a few
celebrities actually we started talking
to and we might be able to convince them
and I think they'll be quite good but
we're open to anyone who shows a passion
for the subject to deep understanding
and they're they're fun to listen to I
you know I when I
Beth and Steve and do those art history
videos I immediately said well wow this
is how I wish I had learned art history
I keep wanting to watch more and more of
these videos they were funny they were
smart they were conversational they were
focused on the content as opposed to the
teacher so that's we we kind of brought
them on board so we're very open to more
of that and and we'll be announcing
another individual very soon who she's
done some amazing things and and we look
forward to announce that as well okay
you've shown the world how the teaching
of math science and a little bit of
history can be changed for the better do
you have ideas for the teaching of
English or the native tongue of wherever
these videos are watched we have some
ideas
we're not implementing them right now I
think things like grammar and vocabulary
are natural fit for some of the
exercises we have now I think videos
could all obviously be powerful as well
and I think things like writing there
could be some element of peer to peer
interaction peer to peer assessment and
and I think for things like language in
particular especially spoken language I
think there could be an element of you
know things like like Skype or Google
Hangouts for people to actually interact
with people who speak that other
language and and kind of get have a kind
of a version of immersion that does not
require you to get on a plane but we're
not we're not able to tackle them in the
very short term but hopefully eventually
we will able to get to those things so
that's a summary of all those ok
accounting videos saved my grades we
actually do hope one to do a much deeper
accounting I eventually want it so that
you can get most of the skills that or
all of the skills and an MBA would learn
from from Khan Academy ok how do I get
my kids to enjoy learning about math and
science my husband and I always
struggled with these subjects so we have
no interest in them and are not
proficient in them at all we don't want
our kids to have the same struggle
advice and I wrote this down and and the
best advice I could give is these two
parents should should immerse themselves
in math and science and realize that it
is fascinating and now there are things
like the Khan Academy that thinking that
can get them up to speed in kind of a
non stressful environment and I think if
they did that they would discover that
they do have an interest in math and
science and as soon as they do that
they're there it will change the culture
in their home and their kids will see
that wow mom and dad are doing
even though no one's forcing them to I
want to do that too and they'll have
wonderful conversations about galactic
collisions and and acids and bases and
who knows what else ok let's go I'm
already at 26 minutes maybe I'll go for
another 10 minutes all right all right
my name is Abhinav and I'm 8 years old I
am doing this with permission of my dad
I like Khan Academy and use it a lot my
question is why do you have questions
and tests for only math and not other
subjects and brilliant question on bean
oven that is on our plate and we are our
goal is you know math is a core subject
that gives a lot of people trouble even
though we think it most people are
capable of doing it very well if they're
given the opportunity and so that's what
we're tackling first although the videos
go well beyond that but do expect to see
much more than just mathematics in in in
the not too far off future I would say
in the next year by the time you're nine
nine years old hopefully that won't be
too late for you you will have things
like finance and physics and chemistry
and accounting and and and logic and
computer science and and many many other
things so hopefully it'll you won't find
it boring as a nine year old okay so
let's see how would you compare the
value of in-person lectures to that of
online learning and you know like many
things it depends I think in-person
lectures even large ones can be very
powerful when there is a shared
experience when it's an inspiration when
it's kind of an idea I think it's I
think it's worse when you're covering
dense material that that different
people will kind of will internalize at
different rates and different people
have different levels of preparation
then when you do this kind of one pace
fits all lecture I think it's not the
most productive use of having 300 person
or even 5,300 people or even 50 people
in the same room I think that is better
served by having on-demand video and and
self-paced select exercises and then
using the the physical time to actually
interact with each other or actually
build things or actually mentor each
other and then how was presenting at Ted
who was the most interesting person you
met Ted was kind of surreal there were a
lot of interesting people there as you
can imagine
maybe one of the most interesting
moments I got out of my hotel room one
morning and I was on the 14th floor and
I got into the elevator and then I saw
this fairly tall individual say hello
Solomon and he just read my nametag he
didn't know who I was and I looked up
and I looked up because he's very tall
and it was ashton kutcher and then and
then I kind of looked on my side and
right on the other side of me was to me
more and then we just kind of went down
the next 14 floors and yeah I didn't
really know what to say so I just looked
down but that was probably my that was
an interesting moment for me but there
was other kind of crazy things that Ted
okay let's see and as I said in the
thing I was actually running a hundred
four fever that night before and I
wasn't going to Kay I was actually
thinking about even calling 911 cuz I
was really just like delusional and
going nuts that night but my wife showed
up the next morning she's a doctor gave
me a ton of acetaminophen and and and I
was good to go on stage and so how was
it when Bill Gates says you're taking a
peek into the future of Education I
would have been peeing in my pants man
and as I said well that wasn't the first
time we had met so I gotten somewhat
used to him although it's still surreal
and it was very surreal to be on stage
with him and I think you know the first
time I met him it was closer to that
scenario but yes it was it was it was
pretty amazing okay let's see let's see
so there's some of them amazing things
here what do you think of em I t's new
online course system especially given
that you're the commencement speaker
which which which I find once again so
real a lot of this is just surreal to me
but I think the the poster is referring
to MIT X where they're going to start
doing online classes not just videos
allowing MIT students to work at their
own pace so that they can use class time
for more interactivity more
project-based things and then they'll
let the whole world benefit from those
virtual self-paced lessons so I'm a big
fan of that I think that by itself is a
game changer but the real big game
changer is that they're going to allow
they're gonna have proctored
examinations that people could take it
sounds like for very little money to
show that they really understood the
concept they're gonna call them mitx
credentials and I think that could be a
super huge game-changer and really
spread shock
through higher education because if
someone takes the MITx credential in
computer science or the MITx credential
and algorithms and and they do well on
it and and that credential really is at
a very rigorous level I would interview
that those people I would I would that
value them as much as someone with a
high GPA from a from a computer science
program and so yeah I think it could be
pretty powerful you could start seeing
people who maybe don't go to college and
I'm not going to advocate one or the
other I I love my college experience
although I don't think this should be a
mandatory experience but you know you
could imagine us a high school student
who shows that they mastered all that
stuff and if they choose that they want
to work before going to college they
could probably get a job and you know a
very good company if they show that they
knew some of that material or at a you
know at an earlier stage and they didn't
need to go to college for it in fact
you'd probably give them bonus points
that they were capable of learning the
material somewhat independently that it
wasn't it didn't have to be they didn't
have to learn it in a formal structure
because frankly at the end of the day
you want the people that when they're 30
years old or they're 40 years old and
they don't have a formal academic
structure they can still learn then you
learn new things because we know that in
the next 10 years or 20 years there's
going to be a ton so when you new new
new things to learn okay all right let's
see so there's a lot of stuff if you
could reform public education what would
you do as I mentioned I think I think
the key here is to provide really
powerful test cases and really powerful
tools that allow the test cases to be
replicable there are amazing cases of
charter schools and public schools doing
amazing things but it's hard to
replicate them I think the combination
of doing things like the Khan Academy
virtually when people can use it however
they see fit and you you put that in
combination with creating examples of
how it's best used and you show that the
students in those examples are not just
5% or 10% better that they are you know
and by anyway you measure them
dramatically better I think that example
setting can kind of create a groundswell
of change but I don't know well you know
what we'll see we'll see what actually
happens what's made you study for so
many degrees I as I said I I was I am I
continue to be very naturally
curious and when I was at MIT it was
almost hard not to register for more
classes and so I did I just heard for as
many as I could and I guess you end up
getting a lot of degrees that way let's
see what were your grades like in high
school as I mentioned they were good
okay let's see so let's see how would
you respond to the idea that some people
believe your video is a replacement or
an improvement on traditional education
I've heard critics caution that people
relying on the Academy to teach them are
doing 20th century learning memorization
drilling with formulas and ideas without
real-world application instead of 21st
century learning application of concepts
to solve new problems I can see both
things as being valuable but I won't ask
you where'd you see the kind of kind of
fitting in the context of a person's
complete education so so I think the
people who who believe that we are
trying to do kind of we're backwards
looking and how we're learning I think
they they believe that we think that the
videos are the complete thing and what
we're saying is that the videos are an
enabler to make the complete thing
happen in the classroom and so to some
degree the fact that we can do the fact
that we can automate some of the the the
stuff that traditionally was done in a
lecture that what we're doing is we are
we're making hopefully the the
traditional passive lecture obsolete I
think there is still some value in
something and getting information in
that way sometimes when you can pause it
and repeat it becomes that much better
but what it does is it frees up time to
do other things my vision of the school
of the future is kids spending most of
their time doing actual exploring things
doing open-ended things doing creative
things I think you'll find that not just
us and the people on our team but most
of our supporters are actually the
people who are defining what a 21st
century job actually is and we talked a
lot about well what are we looking for
in people how do we find those people
who can write who can write a creative
of programs who can design things who
can who can define new things that never
existed before and and that's what we
think about when we try to figure out
what the kind of Academy should become
in terms of memorizing and drilling
the videos I try to take great pains
actually to minimize any form of
memorization actually II hope far less
than even what goes on in most
traditional classrooms you know I think
most of the people who've like the Khan
Academy I think like it because it is so
focused on intuition it is so focused on
understanding things at a deeper level
so that kind of the the formulas just
become almost almost common sense so
yeah so I I don't I don't I don't
necessarily and maybe a you know maybe
I'm wrong here but I don't I don't think
they're necessary perceiving us the way
that we perceive ourselves in terms of a
replacement or an improvement on a
traditional education I do believe that
the traditional model as I said kind of
the Prussian model everyone moving
together a lockstep in these greige
grace age-based cohorts is not helpful
and so I would like to see a more as I
said before American model emerge and
and we'll see we'll see what happens
well we were favorite teachers and I
wrote that here I'll do one more
question I'll do one more question that
might be interesting why I'm starting to
lose my my throat okay let's see how
much time do you spend working on videos
a day how taxing is it well I'm in the
36th minute of this video right now and
you hear that I'm about to lose my voice
but I do try to spend about half the day
at least making videos and on a good day
the whole day making videos but it is
it's incredibly rewarding that's why I
like doing it
but it is taxing once you do four or
five videos your brain is tired and you
want to go do something like take a walk
anyway hopefully hopefully I'll enjoy
that maybe I'll have time maybe tomorrow
morning I might do another maybe I'll
start answering questions below this